[Musik]
eine Bedrohung für österreichsgrenzen
kann nie ganz ausgeschlossen werden doch
wir sind gerüstet mit der Mission
vorwärts des österreichischen
bundeshehres Mission vorwärts ist die
große Neuaufstellung des
österreichischen Bundesheeres über die
nächsten 10 Jahre werden über 16
Milliarden Euro in die Modernisierung
des bundesjahres investiert
die Welt um uns verändert sich und mit
ihr die Herausforderungen denen sich
unser Land stellen muss für die
Sicherheit unserer Bevölkerung ist es
erforderlich mit einem kampfkräftigen
und modernen her für aktuelle und
zukünftige Bedrohungslagen zu rüsten wir
schützen das österreichische
Staatsgebiet und können es im Notfall
auch
verteidigen um bei einer Bedrohung
unserer Grenzen schnellst möglich
reagieren zu können setzen wir aktuell
und in Zukunft folg Maßnahmen
individualschutz für unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten alle unsere Einheiten sind
mit modernster
Schutzausrüstung Spezial Equipment und
Bewaffnung ausgestattet auch für den
Kampf im urbanen Raum Erhöhung der
Mobilität in der Luft zu Wasser und am
Lande im Ernstfall zählt jede Sekunde es
hat für das österische Bundesheer
höchste Priorität die Lage aufzuklären
um schnellst möglich am richtigen
Einsatzort zu sein wir verfügen über
eine hohe Dynamik und Schlagkraft um im
Kampf überlegen zu
sein beste Ausbildungs und
Trainingsmöglichkeiten wir stellen
sicher dass unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten in jeder Waffengattung bestens
aus und weitergebildet werden sie müssen
jeden Tag Einsatz für Einsatz die
höchsten Standards
erfüllen